Parliament is looking at how to reform
the EU long-term budget to meet the
bloc's ambitions in the years to come
the MFF or multi-annual financial
framework enables the EU to administer
its budget across different areas over a
minimum of five years
MEP s want to boost some European
programs including erasmus+ and the
youth employment initiative Parliament
also wants to keep funding key European
policies like support for poor areas and
sustainable agriculture they also want
to fund new priorities we agree that we
need new priorities research innovation
digitalization this is something very
important but we cannot resign from the
old ones but the EU is facing a funding
challenge the bad away over here
verticals across importance to the poor
Chandra GPS good loser for a gap
convened on the whole get off me Yahoo
on one donor list a fella the MFF makes
sure that spending stays within agreed
limits but MEP is wanted to be flexible
enough to cope with new challenges such
as sudden increases in migration flows
or security threats